des repas des sorties dans les rues de
maisons laffitte mais c'est surtout la
peinture qui rythmaient la vie
quotidienne de willem thilleman gros mai
dernier propriétaire privé du château de
maisons d'origine allemande peintre
collectionneurs et grand voyageur il
décide en 1882 d'inviter plusieurs amis
d'entre eux finlandais au château de
maisons et 10 réaliseront plusieurs
oeuvres cette exposition présente dont
pour la première fois depuis 140 ans des
oeuvres qui ont été peintes au château
qui sont conservés en finlande dans
différents musées et collections privées
fernandez et qui retrouve aujourd'hui
des cimaises du château présenté au
premier étage du château des peintures
exécutées par willem thilleman gros mais
les également d'autres réalisées par ses
invités comme adolf von becker ou albert
et die welt on découvre aussi quelques
objets provenant des collections privées
de l'ancien propriétaire du château de
maisons nous présentons des grands
tirages de photographies qui ont été
réalisées à la demande de gros mais
pendant 7
académie artistique il avait commandé un
reportage photographique un photographe
assez connu dans l'histoire de la
photographie française qui s'appelle
louis amédée mentent et nous retrouvons
des grands tirages dans différentes
pièces du château qui évoque la vie de
ces grands propriétaires et peintre
cette oeuvre peinte en 1882 par gunnar
berntsen représente une femme à l'oiseau
bleu l'intérêt est double je dirais
d'une part pour nous
on reconnaît des décors du château donc
on peut apercevoir cette jeune femme qui
posait en fait précisément dans
l'encadrement de cette porte qui ouvre
sur l'anti chambre dite des reculs on
peut à travers ce témoignage avoir une
idée relativement exactes aussi des
coloris qui était ce par exemple des
boiseries du château à cette époque là
samedi 14 et dimanche 15 mai une
reconstitution de cette époque se
tiendra dans le château de maison et son
jardin dans le cadre de l'exposition des
visites chanter auront lieu aussi le 13
mai et le 3 juin prochain
[Musique]